foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here's Morgan on sensor
Russell Brand is back breaking silence
on Rumble with another conspiracy Laden
tirade with advertisers pulling out and
the police now investigating what will
happen to the troubled star
members of England ladies angling team
refused to go to the world championships
in protest over a trans teammate are
they right as physical Braun make a big
difference in the world of angling I
talked to the two women at the very deep
end of this story
ask questions I never thought I'd have
to ask did you wear anal beads while
cheating I get to the bottom of chess's
biggest ever scandal in an exclusive
interview with the new Bad Boy of Chess
hands Neiman
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored I'm going to tell you
a little story it's about an advertising
campaign so helplessly woke and absurd
but I'm convinced it was designed
specifically to irritate me not long ago
in a large glass building filled with
smug people and kale smoothies the
marketing team at HSBC commissioned a
children's author to rewrite three
classic fairy tales you might well think
that's an unusual thing for a bank to do
if you're sitting comfortably I'll allow
them to explain
with financial attitude shaped as early
as five years old the new book
challenges traditional gender
stereotypes it says at this point I've
already lost track really of exactly why
the bank is rewriting fairy tales or
what any of it has got to do with gender
stereotypes but it gets worse the book
called fairer fairer Tales reimagine
Cinderella Sleeping Beauty and Rapunzel
a successful businesswoman Prince
Charming is inevitably erased as the
main character he's a prince and he's
Charming but apparently that's not
enough the marketing Geniuses decided to
pay tennis player emiraticanu to read
the stories reasons which remain unclear
this is how it went
Ace where have you been the boys and
girls are here and they're waiting to
hear the three Tails about
money
my name's Emma and this is Ace we have a
fantastic story for you today now the
story may seem like one you know but the
characters in it are a little bit
different
it's hard to believe that the tennis
ball exchanging hilarious banter with
emerald akanu in the video is not real
it's CGI Believe It or Not Emma is a
tennis player not an actor but let's not
distract from the powerful core message
so in the end the princesses didn't need
a prince to save them they set up their
own businesses save their money and then
spent it very wisely
[Music]
thanks to our princesses Aces learned
some new money skills maybe you'll buy a
tower one day or set up your own shoe
business or any business you want
now that you've learned how to save and
spend money you can do anything
of course as we all know the best way to
improve the aspirations of women is by
trashing men and as Emma says women
don't need men at all she certainly
never needed any men as far as we know
to get where she is today except well a
father of course who manages her career
and well fathered her and then there are
her five coaches who so far have all
been male or Max Eisenberg her agent who
apparently is very very good at
maximizing her earning potential despite
being a man and then a final Twist of
his dastardly tale of virtue signaling
treachery it turns out the chairman
chief executive and Chief Financial
Officer on hsbc's board of directors are
all men too well joining me now is
taught to be contributor Esther cracker
Associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
socialist author Grace Blakely Grace
uh I don't know where to start with this
I mean part of the fact that as a man
let me just offer this rather Garden
some advice I think she's great uh and
when she won the US Open it was amazing
but she hasn't won a shoebox since then
and I think she's spending too much time
on this commercial stuff and not enough
time on the call that's my personal view
as a man take it leave it crash it
whatever you want I think you're missing
actually the most important part of this
story right which isn't like the the big
man versus women battle that we're all
supposed to take aside in it's about
that HSBC is a massive International you
know bank that has frequently been
accused of uh things like money
laundering it was accused of money
laundering for Mexican drug cartels it
was accused of supporting tax avoidance
and evasion it's frequently threatened
the government of the UK to relocate to
another part of the world if it if we
you know um say do something like raise
tax tax on corporations or if we start
regulating financial sector properly and
this is basically attempt an attempt a
kind of pink washing it saying don't
look at all the terrible things that
we've been embroiled in over the last
several decades don't look at the fact
that we're basically trying to undermine
democracy by by telling you what laws
you can and can't pass just look at the
fact that we've done a nice pretty
little fairy tale and oh by the way if
you're a woman and you start a business
then that's great and that makes you a
good woman feminism isn't for people who
don't get the chance to stop and it
certainly isn't a great thing to be a
woman at HSBC where the vast majority of
the people that run the bank yeah are
actually men I mean that's the problem
with this it's a bit like Barbie the
movie it's a bit like all these things
there's a kind of subtext here of well
men are pointless and annoying and you
should never not just rely on them but
have them in your life because they
sponge men from the world and all will
be fine well yes but I think that we
should be more concerned with why a bank
or any business feels the need to
actually do this I I don't remember
asking HSBC what they think about fairy
tales or women in business or anything
like that why can't they just be a
business why do businesses feel the need
to to lecture us or take a particular
political position as if we need them as
our moral
I totally agree I mean Kevin is that all
right Kevin we've seen this time and
again now companies just doing these
woke advertising campaigns none of which
work right there's an immediate backlash
from all their customers who don't like
this kind of thing I think it's a
growing number of people whether you're
Bud Light or Gillette when they play
this stunt or any of these others now we
have this it's not going to work it's
not going to achieve what they think it
is people aren't going to go fantastic
age busy they're I going to say what
Grace said which is you're just a bunch
of flaming Hypocrites or they're going
to say stop talking to me about this
stuff just make my bank do do its job be
a banker that's why I love it because it
backfires it is entirely cynical by this
bank which look you open a business with
them you can't keep up your repayments
on a loan and they'll have you they'll
have the shirt off your back they'll
have your handbag your shoes I love your
house they'll have every lust any you've
got but somehow there's a whole industry
convincing them they should do this
whoever's doing it a good look to the
advertising people who get them to do
this can I just say uh I kudos to
emiraticanu's agent for actually getting
her this morning because she's a
terrible actress she looks like as
wooden as a board and she doesn't I
believe what she's reading I think there
is an important underlying story here
right which is the reason that we've had
this explosion in kind of you know green
washing pink washing things like ethical
consumption is that most people realize
that the system we live in is incredibly
unfair they want to you know do things
to support to prevent climate breakdown
they want to do things to support you
know equal rights and and prevent you
know the economy from privileging
certain people over others and
corporations are basically trying to
make money out of this just like they're
making money out of the climate work
dying just like they're making money out
of the gap between between okay let's
move on to
this concept of making money out of
things and who shouldn't who shouldn't
so Russell Brand today the Met police in
the last few hours Kevin have announced
that they are launching a police
investigation into what they call
Historic allegations we don't know we
don't know who it's from we don't know
which of the stories but other people
who came forward to the Sunday Times at
Channel 4 whether they're new people
they haven't explained yet exactly who
these accusers are but it's certainly
multiple people and it takes it to where
I've wanted this to go which is legal
due process we're now going to have a
proper police investigation but what
still concerns me about the story is
what is going on off the back of the
original investigation which is this
sort of huge concerted effort to cancel
Russell Brand who is now doing exactly
what I knew he would do he's he's
exploiting that to say look it's all a
Witch Hunt they're all trying to shut me
down let's take a little look at his
clip on Rumble today
plainly this is a story that is much
bigger than me plainly The Trusted news
initiative has an agenda an explicit
agenda to throttle and choke Independent
Media plainly the government are
reaching out to ask big Tech platforms
to suppress the voices of content
creators from Independent Media Outlets
particularly those that are dissenting
and as you have seen many of those media
organizations have been willing to
comply
Now esther this is all heading to a very
dark place I think you now have Russell
Brown facing a serious police
investigation into rape sexual abuse all
sorts of very serious allegations but
he's just carrying on like nothing's
happened he did a two-hour rant today
with all sorts of conspiracy fueled
stuff his normal sort of stick
um what do you feel about the way he's
behaving a lot of these allegations
there's no apology there's no
clarification there's just this ongoing
no it's all a Witch Hunt and also the
way the world is responding to these
allegations yeah well I saw this coming
because this is this is why I said
originally these women should have gone
to the police because now we live in an
era when someone is being attacked like
this it's automatically a conspiracy and
I just think there's nothing that
particularly special about Russell Brand
he's not an intellectual luminary for
the likes of CNN or any of these massive
media corporations to be scared of the
reality is he has been accused of
something very serious and the the law
should to should play out the reality is
at the end of the day he's going to keep
going and saying that this is a
conspiracy against him because like he
says he's maintaining his innocence so
if he's innocent he's not going to be
great but Grace what we what we have now
is you see a trend Donald Trump sort of
started this really Boris Johnson has
done a bit of it too where regardless of
the allegation or its seriousness you
simply say it's a Witcher you simply say
it's mainstream Legacy Media combining
with big Tech combining the government
and I'm a victim here so this kind of
turning the thing on its head and using
victimhood as a protective shield
against this and they've got millions of
people who go along with this well again
you know I think this is it's similar to
The Last Story and you led on from it in
the sense that people are people like
Russell Brand are taking advantage of a
climate basically of kind of fear and
mistrust they exists in our society
because of the massive disparities of
power that do exist there right there is
you know a massive coordination in terms
of the power of small number of media
organizations it is difficult for
smaller media organizers to get through
that there are you know a lot of very
troubling things that um have been you
know done or covered up by people at the
top of our society whether we're looking
at you know billions of dollars
distributed to private corporations
during the financial crisis or covid or
whatever people know that the people at
the top of our society do not have their
best interests at heart and often lie to
them about what is actually going on and
that is what fuels conspiracy and Kevin
the trouble is when when we had the
chair of the Parliamentary committee uh
Caroline dionage I think it is and she
wrote to the bosses of all the of the
big tech companies to say you've got to
stop monetizing this guy that kind of
overreach by politicians plays
completely into the hands of Russell
Brand and his followers that's like
clear evidence of a of of the State
trying to overreach isn't it I always
feel very uncomfortable about
politicians using their positions to
exert uh pressure that way however if I
was running a company I wouldn't want my
ads on his on his Channel at the moment
when he's facing these accusations and
one way he's right it is bigger than him
but not in the way he means and the way
it's bigger is one of the reasons
um only one in every hundred reported
rapes in the UK end up in court with a
prosecution is because too many powerful
men and the authorities of uh
not as amazing in the interests of women
right I mean what is amazing is the BBC
revealed a couple of days ago a news
story involving a woman who went on the
record saying that in Los Angeles he had
come into a a bathroom uh where she was
and he'd exposed himself to her and said
I'm gonna you know sexually have sex
with you and she said no you're not was
disgusted and whatever and she's only
now come forward and said it again
allegations but what's extraordinary is
it then 25 minutes later he's on the
Airways on the BBC joking about this and
saying you know the guy says 25 minutes
ago he was showing a woman you're Willy
right so the BBC's got this big archive
now stuff yeah well they've just
broadcast almost confessional stuff from
your brand about this stuff why were
they not doing more standards and
practices at the time uh
mistakes frightened uh in all of him
whatever it is look his free speech he
was he was that he was a darling of that
subject
of British
history was it because of the time he
was a left-wing darling oh for goodness
wow I do I honestly have we not seen any
right wing
uh you know alligator
games
the left wing decided he was a superstar
he attended Guardian editorial
conferences sitting next to the other
surrounding Ross Bridge who's now
outraged by him he wrote a column for
the guardian for seven years he appeared
at their conferences he edited the new
Statesman he was on all this stuff right
he was he was being given and yet they
they must have known about the stuff
that was going out on the BBC at the
same time we didn't know what the
guardian thing hang on expose himself to
a woman there was a there was a culture
of permissiveness where powerful men
could joke about sleeping and abusing
and flashing to women it was all
considered a laugh yeah you go back in
British TV you think of Benny Hill yeah
I just think of it you can come up
happen to people on the right too but
I'd want to make the point his free
speech is not infringe because he can
say what he likes but we can't
we cannot say it because of libel laws
which he uses defamation laws which he's
been very ready to do before and also
there are just legal restrictions now
because the police are getting him you
know it raises a lot of issues I'm just
glad the police are now investigators we
may get to the bottom of it where it
becomes irrefutable right if there's a
proper legal process I would hope we get
to the the facts and the truth uh muscle
not to diminish the accusers they may
well be telling 100 the truth but we
know also sadly sometimes accusers do
not tell the truth I mean they've got to
be fair to everyone whoever they are um
let's turn to uh John Federman who's
this senator in America who's obviously
had a lot of health issues but they've
now changed the law not the law but they
changed the rules of the Senate that you
can now because he says he gets
triggered by having to wear certain
clothing to work because of his
condition he now can go in dress like
this and he's been wearing shorts and
hoodies and all sorts of stuff I mean
Kevin even you now now appear on
television in a smart way even you put a
jacket and shirt on right even here when
we drop when we drop the standards of
things like the U.S Senate it'd be like
a British Parliament it's been somebody
there saying I get triggered by wearing
suits and we saw someone coming in in
shorts and a hoodie come on they changed
actually in the British Parliament the
House of Commons and the Chamber the
rules on having to wear a tie because it
was an MP who couldn't uh fix a tie
because of a medical condition look it's
between him and his constituents the
people who elected
election they go in public and moon
members of the public or pull down his
travels I'm sorry the reason why you are
you have you need to act and dress like
like the uh like you have respect for
the office that you occupy it's not very
difficult to put on a shirt well I'll
tell you hang on what freedom of
expression okay we have freedom of
speech freedom of course those are
supposed to be no no those are the
liberal rights upon Which democracy
British democracy we are on this show
all the time talking about the
importance of free speech the importance
of protecting against the despotism of
the States freedom of expression falls
into that category as well
you know what do you know people my
mother my mother always said to me dress
as if you're gonna meet the queen okay
you go to work dresses if you're going
to meet the Queen's a pretty good rule
right yeah what if you're a Republican
and you think Queen is just the same as
anyone else if you want to meet the
president if he meets the Queen he can
empty your bins dress like that earlier
what was funny was a New York Post and a
journalist around all the top
restaurants in New York dressed like I
am in the hoodie and shorts and most of
them said you're not coming in here
that's very funny uh I want to leave
with a little tribute to Megan rapino
the world's most annoying sports star
who's now retired from International uh
soccer uh and she said this
I feel like the stuff off the field is
um
like the reason I'm you know here on
this planet that feels like my life's
working something that just feels like
breathing to me so I love that work
um you know I love being able to
leverage this amazing platform and
um
use that to you know in some way make
the world a better place oh shut up
honestly good for us
kick a round little bowl around that's
it nobody wants to you see you make the
world a better place let me tell you
what she means by this stuff off the
pitch is that now she's retired now she
says she wants to see biological males
who've transitioned to be trans women
playing the Women's National Soccer Team
not while she was playing herself so
they couldn't take her place uh these
biological males but now she'd be quite
happy for that type of fact she wants it
to happen if that's what your
contribution is to women's rights
because she's basically saying look at
me I did all this stuff a woman's rights
actually miss Rabino what you've done
you've left with a little sting in the
tail is that now having fought for
women's rights for pay uh parity and so
much I totally applaud you for now
you've left endorsing something that
would destroy women's rights to fairness
and equality that is your legacy anyone
got a thought yeah the program it's
absolutely absurd to suggest you know
the reason that she's left at this point
is because her life has become so
difficult as she's tried to campaign for
Fantasy quality for trans women in sport
even as she's you know fought for a very
very long time to get through all of
these measures that you've just said
have been really really important we've
reached the stage where the political
debate about trans people has become so
tall
and says I'm a woman
Grace
can early Harland if he says I now
identify as a woman playing the
norwegiance city massive he's the best
striker in the world he's six foot four
he's a massive Beast he scores goals
every 10 seconds in the men's game are
you happy decided yeah become trans go
through all of the horror the just like
the stuff I did no no you go through
nothing he he saw the advice as trans he
deals with all of the pushback on social
media the debt
as a result of that and then says
then you know the the team would be able
to legitimately make a decision that's
whether or not that was awesome that is
exactly that is the Megan rapino
position right there you are our Megan
rapino you've just destroyed you're
saying that I'm an international women's
soccer player no I'm saying you're
relatively irritating uh uh taking
position which is always wrong and on
this one and on this one you have just
endorsed early Harland playing women's
football which of course would destroy
women's football congratulations women's
rights nil I didn't but look look
biological sex matters right yeah and
Men born as men shouldn't be playing
yeah in sport Rapido Free Speech what's
wrong with that
and by the way nothing will move me
exercising my right to free speech to
say it's complete a bit like Gracie's
position on Ellie Ireland who she only
just heard a man can apparently destroy
women's football
it would it would but thank you Pat good
to see you all and since the next I get
to the bottom of chess's biggest ever
scandal with bad boy hands Neiman is one
of my most probing interviews ever and
the language has been used very
deliberately here we're talking chess
and anal beads it's not for the
faint-hearted this next thing this
interview
[Music]
foreign
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again I'm
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to Piers of organization
Hans Neiman is a name that may not mean
much to you but he's a chest Prodigy in
fact right now he's the most
controversial chess player perhaps ever
for the past year he's been at the
center of a salacious Scandal that has
rocked his sport and I sat down for an
exclusive head to head with hands and
his lawyer but first of all let's take a
look at how this Scandal unfolded Hans
Neiman is the Wild Child of Chess a year
ago this 20 year old U.S Prodigy beat
legendary world champion Magnus Carlson
causing major vibrations in the sporting
world wasn't just Neiman's Bishops
causing the buzz Carlson sensationally
accused him of cheating with sparked
frenzy speculation including a claim
that Neiman used anal beads even Elon
Musk weighed in now Neiman does admit to
cheating twice when he was 12 and 16
with computers but he says he never did
it in person and he insists he never
used anal beads
how could I you know he sued Carlson 100
million dollars the case has now been
settled out of court so will there be a
rematch and can he rebuild his battered
reputation and once and for all didn't
he or didn't it
use the beads tonight I'll find out Hans
Neiman goes uncensored
well I'm joined Now by Hans Neiman and
by his lawyer Terence over if the first
question uh hands for you why have you
got your lawyer with you
well uh considering the the recent uh
case and settlement are some legal
questions I'm you know my my lawyer
might be able to better answer and to be
honest uh I'm you know Terry and his
team has been frankly you know great and
and helping me resolve this case and uh
I'm very very thankful to them for
believing in me and you know this is not
just a he's not just my lawyer he's a
friend he's a confidante and he's
someone who I trust uh fully and uh
that's why he's here today okay so look
you you are a chess Prodigy no question
you're a grand master which you got that
title into 17 you ranked the fourth best
Junior chess player in the world so
you're a brilliant chess player the
question mark that got put over your
head came after you beat Norway's world
champion Magnus Carlson this is back in
Missouri in September 2022 so a year ago
and you beat him ending a 53 game
unbeaten streak and as a result you're
accused of being a cheat and you're
accused of cheating in a particularly
fascinating manner which is the
allegation was that your coach had
basically instructed you to insert anal
beads inside yourself which he would
then send remote signals to uh first of
all when that story broke those
allegations what was your reaction
well obviously it's very disheartening
to be accused of cheating after after
that Victory
um but you know uh
these things you know it happened and I
learned a lot from that time and uh it
really has taught me a lot of very very
important lessons about life and chess
and I think it's only strengthened my
resolve okay but just to be clear you
didn't cheat
of course not so what have you what have
you had to learn if you didn't cheat
well I think uh The Learning Experience
was more so the media attacking me and
uh all the you know trustworld you know
crashing down on me I think learned you
know dealing with that you know was a
learning experience you know dealing
with all that pressure and competing
under all that pressure but but again to
be clear on the specific allegation have
you ever used anal beads while playing
chess
not a question I ever thought I'd ask a
guest to be honest but uh well you know
your curiosity is a bit concerning you
know maybe you're personally interested
but uh I can tell you no
okay categoric no
of course yes categorically no I
obviously I didn't I didn't make the
allegations I'm just repeating what was
put to you at the time as a result of
the fury that developed
um you were investigated by chess.com
they banned you while they did this and
they published a report uh saying that
you would likely cheated more than a
hundred times in online games you've
been admitted you had cheated I think
twice you said uh in online games on
chess.com when you were 12 and 16 but
denied ever doing so in an in-person
game is that an accurate assessment of
what went down
that's correct
given you've admitted to cheating
is it completely outrageous that people
thought you may have continued cheating
well let me just clarify that the
chess.com report where they you know
accuse me of cheating over 100 games is
completely defamatory and you know as
outlined in my lawsuit uh you know the
person who actually wrote that report
Danny wrench told me himself uh that
they knew that I had never cheated while
streaming and the most serious
accusations in that report
happened while I was streaming live on
Twitch and the only reason that they
banned me uh you know was because they
were finalizing you know merger with the
play Magnus group and their new you know
you know star Ambassador was making a
mockery of himself and they needed to
back up his accusations and discredit me
so just a convers.com's report accusing
me of 100 games of cheating is frankly
ridiculous and the timing that they
decided to ban me you know only during
this merger and only after uh this
accusation you know it's absolutely
ridiculous and that report should not be
taken seriously whatsoever unstable but
just to be clear again
um
and when you did cheat the ones you've
admitted to what were the circumstances
of cheating
well I was 12 years old uh in the uh I
was very young it was not a
it was uh you know a tournament but it
was a childish mistake and something
I've admit to and I don't think that uh
something you do when you're 12 and
something you know with you know a
couple hundred bucks in the line uh
should have any but how did you expect
uh someone was it was like an iPad
so someone was giving you moves from an
iPad
mm-hmm yes it was a uh it was a very
childish thing I had no I didn't even
understand the seriousness of what was
happening but then you were 16 and did
it again was it the same the same thing
again when you were 16. well when I was
when I was 16 this was not a prize money
event these were random meaningless
games it's like you know
it was a similar similar manner you see
so the first one you could put down to
being a 12 year old kid all right you
make a mistake you learn your lesson you
move on but to do it again four years
later when you're 16
so anyway four years ago why did you do
it again
I I saw those use those games as
meaningless
um and they were meaningless there was
no money or anything attached to them
and um again it was a child or something
I was living on my own when I was 16.
um I was financially independent and uh
I felt a lot of pressure you know I just
simply wanted to to get a higher rating
on on the website but I want to make a
differentiation Pierce when you when you
talk about online chess and in person
chess this is a very very different
thing and you need to understand the
difference between that these online
games these are absolutely absolutely
meaningless so I don't like people that
cheat in any form of competitional sport
because to me it just kills the
integrity and purity of it and I guess
you would agree with that right
no of course so but you should
understand you know the difference
between when you're you know young child
and you're under severe pressure and and
you make a mistake and you know you
should also understand that uh when it
comes to over-the-board official
tournaments I've never cheated and
there's absolutely no evidence that I've
ever cheated
here's the problem with that I I like I
say when you're 12 all right I get it
but to do the same thing again when
you're 16 shows there's a pattern well
we only we only actually have your word
for it right I mean there might not be
hard evidence to have nailed you but you
can understand why people be suspicious
given your emissions
Pierce we understand Hans was 16 years
old he made a mistake we understand that
you have a different uh interpretation
he was playing online in a game that
really didn't matter at a young age we
understand and you're not wrong but to
try to extrapolate from the fact of
something that he did on an online game
when he was 16 and say once a cheater
always a cheater if you did something
when you were 16 I'm gonna hold it
against you for the rest of your life we
think that's a little harsh and it
certainly doesn't properly characterize
all right but why couldn't he answer
that question
sorry
yeah hands I mean it was really MDU you
know if you cheat in a sport once
I can give you analogy as well so let's
say that you know you know you know
16 year old kid went into like a pickup
basketball game that is the equivalent
of the games that I cheated in at 16
years old is the equivalent of a
meaningless pickup basketball game do
you think that that should should Define
my entire career especially you know
you're using you're using you know
computerized systems to some way of to
understand
I can't think of a more egregious way of
cheating than doing that you're using a
non-human brain to beat a human I mean
it's just
he did not do that here but he didn't he
did not do that here meaning what he did
back then what he did about five years
ago and then about 10 years ago you're
correct he's uh he's admitted that and
he's apologized for that yeah but that
has absolutely nothing to do with what
happened here any nothing else could be
closer to the truth
well on says the next thing
to do with Hans name and if you thought
part one was buzzing with Revelations
you might need to distract yourself in
for round two
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'll go back to Facebook so now uh the
second part of my exclusive interview
with the chess bad boy Grand Master Hans
Neiman things get a little touchy so
yesterday I believe you played Vladimir
kramnik on chess.com and you beat him
and Crown Nick said afterwards I've
decided to stop playing on chess.com
from tomorrow on just too many obvious
cheaters on here nothing is done to
clean the platform from these small
Crooks harsh words but true what did you
make of that
well the creme situation is quite
complex because I actually beat him
about a week ago and uh he made a video
that was a bit confusing but actually a
couple days ago I had private
correspondence with him where he told me
that he has personally has no issue with
me and where he said that uh he was not
meant to be an accusation whatsoever
so um
blatant suggestion that you cheated
well that contradicts uh you know the
direct you know the the private
correspondence an email that he sent to
me but why would he actually invitably
infer you're a cheat in public in the
way that he did that was yesterday well
he but he he is he my name was never
mentioned you know he's just accused a
lot of people of cheating he's accused
yeah but he's he he played that same day
he played against you know 10 other
people right and considering that I was
invited by him to Amsterdam to meet him
and to play games with him
um it seems a bit weird uh that you know
that he would do that you know and then
the next day supposedly accused me of
cheating so you know I understand that
how it might look but uh you know he's
privately reached out to me and I was
invited to Amsterdam I unfortunately
can't go um due to another conflict but
I hope to meet him and to discuss things
in more detail with him okay you sued um
the real damage of this also Pierce
isn't that the real damage as well so
whenever now someone beats someone
rather than acknowledge it and say that
I'll get better now this is set a
precedent that whenever someone beats
you well yeah
you take it away from them yes but I'm
unfortunately actions have consequences
if you admit you've cheated twice over a
four year period uh and you become a
grand master the year after the second
time and you announce only 20 now people
are gonna obviously God's dispersions
on those two isolated incidents why
don't you focus on them is one the two
your clients admitted of course but the
other the other hundreds of matches that
is one are those totally meaningless so
you can always focus on the shade I
don't know I don't know I can only
majority I'm not judging your client I'm
just saying he's admitted to cheating
twice Over a four-year period and that's
why maybe people are in meaningless
games you know I mean people do wonder
they do wonder how did you beat Magnus
Carlson
um okay well if you want to take that
logic you know you want to take that
logic right so I have proven my strength
right chest.com themselves have said
that since I you know since they gave me
a short band before they said that since
then I have never cheated so
on their website I've beaten some of the
best players in the world I've performed
at the highest level on their website
which they they themselves say that I
didn't cheat in in addition to that
and over the board tournaments I have
continued to play Chess at a very very
high level I have
you know you know my ranking my ranking
did not just drop I continue to play
well even after this Victory I've proven
my my chest level and my chest strength
time and time again this is simply a
case of of you know where bullies or or
you know going after someone because
they threaten their business interests
of course he's a bully he used his
entire Empire he used his connections to
just.com he leveraged his you know the
fact that there's a you know a merger
happening and he got all of these people
to attack me and it was it's a bully
it's a simple thing but you know I don't
you know let people bully me I'm going
to stand up to him when I stood up to
him and you know I look forward to
competing him and against the board
again and uh you know I'm gonna you know
do what I do best and improve myself are
you still suing him for 100 million
dollars
no you drop that
the case has been resolved Pierce yeah
did he correct did he pay any money or
we can't discuss that
okay
kind of Interest how do you how do you
disprove that you've used anal beads to
cheat
how could I you know prove disprove a
negative it's like oh no no you expect
me that was never a serious thing that
was something that the media caught up
but that was you know if you if you look
at the the consensus among chess players
the consensus among experts it is an
unequivocal fact that I have never
treated an over-the-board game yeah I'm
just wondering how do you disprove it I
mean were you strip searched did they
explore cavities where do we go here
well through tournaments there are
security checks where they you know will
do you know various Security checks you
know metal detectors different scanners
um
would that pick up anal based
I don't know appears I I have no
genuinely cute you should you should
invite them on your show and ask them
that appears that that's the main topic
of your curiosity appears to be that as
opposed to the fact that you have a 19
year old champion who defeated a
champion who defeated the whole world of
Chess and the largest cyber bullying
case in history the world of Chess
versus Hans Neiman and he's here to talk
about it and he's still a Victor and
instead of becoming bitter he became
better and you want to ask him about the
anal beats something he never said or
never did we don't know the answer to
that question Pierce maybe you can ask
the anal beat people have them on your
show and they can explain it to you
better I think it will because it's
actually a fast listen I love chess I
was my school my Prep School you seem to
love anal beads better at Pierce well
that was my Prep School chess champion I
never cheated you're a better person
you're a better person your words not
mine Terence
uh but I'm just I'm genuinely curious it
was a massive story as you know it's why
you're famous outside of uh the Chess
World is because there was this
allegation made and it was fueled by the
world champion who couldn't understand
how in normal circumstances you would
beat him uh and then came Mrs many
people of my same ranking many times so
this idea that it's a statistical
anomaly he can lose one game and and
that's the issue right he lost to people
similar age similar rating multiple
times recently so me beating him in a
singular game is not a statistical
anomaly right he hasn't agreed to play
you as I understand it is he is he
chickening out what's the deal there
no he has agreed to play me he put out a
public statement that he he will play
there's no date right
well when we were matched in tournament
which which is inevitable uh uh uh we
will play and will you allow yourself to
be strip searched just to rule out any
rumors
I find that question to be just you know
I can't take you seriously when you ask
those questions peers I'm sorry because
you're entertaining uh uh uh honestly an
allegation that should should not even
be taken seriously because it's it's
purely you know for you know for you to
get media attention when this when this
is it's not even a serious thing how
could how can you as a reporter take
that allegation seriously at all well I
understand no but I know you genuinely
believe that no but dude do you actually
believe that that is the case I don't
know could you could you even I don't
know I know you're capable of cheating
because you've admitted it I don't know
how far you go you cheated twice in
before I've never cheated in an over the
board game I've never well I'm clearly
not I'm not capable and I've never
cheated over the board games
right we have your words one word it's
unequivocal
um themselves said that right it is an
unequivocal statistical fact that I have
never cheated in over the board game and
that is something you cannot debate Elon
Musk as you know tweeted uh on what was
known as Twitter then is now X Talent
hit to Target no one else can hit genius
hits a Target no one can see because
it's in your butt
what did you feel when you read that
well I was a bit surprised
um you know uh I was surprised uh you
know I I didn't really think much of it
you know I I focused on competing and um
I don't let these things affect me and
uh my goal is to become the best chess
player in the world and and to give back
to chess players all around the world
and uh I think that chess is a beautiful
game that should be spread and that's
why I intend to do a lot more charity
work and give back to the communities
who helped me do you think when you play
Magnus Carlson again you'll kick his
butt for one of a better phrase
you know I'll just let my chest speak
for itself
and Terence your lawyer thank you both
very much indeed
thank you
still not quite sure what that lawyer
was doing there uh to be honest with you
or where the truth lies with Hans Neiman
the bad boy of Chess did he or didn't he
I don't think I'm any of the wiser after
that we know he does cheat or has done
but did he go that far what a story if
he did you can see the full uncut
interview with Hansen there's plenty
more on the Piers Morgan uncensored
YouTube channel it's worth looking in
full fascinating fascinating story we're
coming out tonight England's women's
fishing team has pulled out of the world
angling championships in protest at a
trans Anglers inclusion in their squad
does physical power of a biological male
whose transition does that actually have
a huge impact in fishing well apparently
it does and we'll talk to those of a
deep end of this right after the break
[Music]
foreign
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war this is making me cry again I'm
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die Behind Bars and I've
seen your doctor who first raised
concerns about that he wants NHS
managers to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what seven
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 pm
the Kentucky party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stopped producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
coming up on the talk Russell brandenbox
and a bizarre rant about Free Speech
after police launched a probe into
sexual assault allegations against the
presenter plus which is soon after
accused of abandoning the North in a
gross Act of vandalism as he considers
axing whole stretches of hs2 and find
out which English City Center has been
available as the country's capital of
shoplifting that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook members of the
England ladies angling team have refused
to compete in this year's World
Championships the decision comes after a
trans woman Becky Lee Burke whistle
Hodges a former male rugby player was
picked for the team on England's angling
trust in governing bodies as trans women
have no advantage over biological women
many of England's star female Anglers
however vehemently disagree here to
explain after the captain of England
ladies annual team Heather Linfield and
Wendy Metcalf a former England ladies
angling star who's described by North
new Norfolk news as a leading figure of
the sport so welcome to both of you uh
all right let me start with you Heather
if I may
there's a kind of belief from the
governing bodies here that being a
biological male would have no impact on
the sport of angling is that right
that's what they're saying and it it's
not true but they do not realize that
they're mixing us up with course Anglers
game Anglers sea fishing we're battling
the elements of the the weather there's
weed there's the the tide it's even
walking in in the water getting knocked
over because we're women we cannot cast
as far and you know sort of uh majority
of men are well over a hundred hundred
yards women aren't getting that distance
whatsoever and it's just about the
unfairness to us women
um you know with with
um transgenders being on the team and
it's not fair competitiveness for those
like me who don't who don't fish much my
brother's a massive Keen fisherman has
been his whole life so he he would know
but if you can cast twice as far or more
than one of your competitors what
advantage does that give you
well you've got obviously more water
that you can cover sometimes there's
fish that's further out you get fish
that sort of like do come close into
Shore and lots of majority of fish can
be further out so when you're fishing
you've got far more choice if you can
cast further than uh than a woman female
okay let me bring in Wendy you pulled
out of England team in 2018 because of
all this uh well I've covered a lot of
this stuff about uh trans women
beginning to dominate and in My Views
start to ruin women's sport and
integrity women's sport why did you feel
so strongly about it
I feel strongly about it I feel very
strongly about it I think that this is
nothing about Becky Lee this is nothing
against Becky Lee herself as a person
what she does in her in her life is
entirely up to her it's no concern of
ours the problem is she has a
significant amount of upper body
strength and it's not fair it's not a
fair and Level Playing Field peers
something's got to happen something the
angling trust have really got to sit up
and take notice of this it's really not
fair I mean what's fascinating to me is
that this is really a point of principle
for both of you because of course it
gives England an unfair advantage and
therefore we would have a better chance
presumably of winning big competition so
you guys are really making a stand Wendy
on a genuine point of principle which
would actually harm your chances of
success
yeah absolutely and I'm very proud that
the England ladies this year have pulled
out
um I just can't thank them enough for
for standing their ground it's about
time that something was done about it
um and yes you're right um if we had
Becky Lee in the team it would give us
an advantage but if we won a medal which
I believe they did
um when Becky Lee was put in the team
when they were when the angling trust
said that that she wouldn't be entered
into the team
um they won bronze medal but it's a
hollow Victory Pierce it's not right
no it's not and Heather I think this is
the problem with all these is that
nobody feels good about this and I don't
feel good about uh this trans athlete
this trans official woman fisherman
whatever she wants to call herself it
doesn't matter to me but what matters to
me is the Integrity of women's sports uh
being preserved and that women's rights
to equality and fairness are not
destroyed in the process
yeah exactly I I'm sort of um you know
I've done a 20 odd year
um stint at this and I just want it
right for the people who are coming in
and who are who haven't got the voice
because they're too scared in case
they're not chosen to or selected for a
team and they they won't speak up
because they're they're afraid of this
whereas I want to leave what I have put
my whole life into
I want it leaving then save hands for us
women yeah and I just don't understand I
don't understand why this particular uh
person Becky can't just continue to
compete with biological men which is her
biological sex was as a male why can't
she just keep doing that with people who
are of the same physical build
yeah that's what that's my my main point
is to Becky Lee if you're watching this
why don't you put all your efforts into
campaigning to get your own
um category that would make sense yeah
can you imagine can you imagine peers
what it would be like in the future the
whole of the women's team could be
transgender well I think it's honestly I
I like I say I've done Lots on this
issue I think it's ridiculous I think
he's got to stop and we've got to
protect women's sport thank you we run
out of time ladies thank you both very
much indeed for joining me and good on
you for sticking out of your principles
that's it for me whatever up to Keep It
Uncensored good name
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign